sortez cette vidéo je vous en supplie
avant j'aurais dit sortez la cette vidéo
je vous le demande moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'était une nouvelle boom qui est venu
secouer le petit monde de la télé
réalité ce week-end un candidat accusé
d'agression sexuelle sur mineur par une
ancienne candidate alix des moineaux
nous a montré une vidéo et ses vidéos
d'agression sexuelle alice ce soit vous
venez nous voir pour 7 a fait un
incroyable
cette vidéo alors à conduire parce que
apparemment comme on l'a vu dans l'ain
dans le récapitulatif il ya une vidéo
qui tourne et d'un candidat donc de télé
réalité qui a fait de nombreuses télé
réalité
qui aurait eu un comportement déplacé
très déplacé avec une jeune fille
mineure cessa de 16 ans et ça alors ce
qu'il avait sur cette vidéo en fait
parce que c'est vous qui avez en fait
c'est vous qui avez vraiment mais quand
c est l inverse oui c'est une lanceuse
d'aller régency donc assise sur un bord
de lit ou jeux pas trop enfin sur un
truc une tyrannie et la personne en
question ça avance vers elle n'a pas de
pantalon un tee-shirt et un t-shirt
blanc donc j'espère que cette vidéo sera
retrouvé et c'est très drôle visiblement
on attrape la jeune fille par les
cheveux elle veut pas dit non on essaye
de lui demander des faveurs et elle
refuse elle pleure moi j'ai vu une
personne en fait la journée aux autres
très ému vous racontez je pense que
n'importe qui vous vous tous vous voyez
cette vidéo vous ne pouvez pas rester la
jeune fille pleure elle hurle et a dû
son aile dure une minute trente elle
pleure elle supplie elle dit je t'en
supplie arrête non moi je suis désolé 1
mais non ça veut dire nantes commence
cette vidéo circule en fait alors moi je
vais vous expliquer dans quel cadre on
l'a montré parce qu'ils trouvent que
c'est une personne publique également
qui me l'a montré dans une conférence de
presse je vais vous dire à quelle
conférence de presse c'était la
conférence de presse après les
marseillais contre le résume la fao et
là on m'a sorti la vidéo et pendant que
je regardais horrifié j'avais une
personne qui jacassent et dans mon
oreille me dire avais tu te rends compte
en plus la fille est allée saison
puisqu'elle n'a pas sa carte d'identité
plaqué sur le front et j'ai pas en vente
et en détails sordides parce que je
pense que c'est assez sale comme ça
c'est un milieu de la chance fait tous
des lâches
armand et les productions protègent
certaines choses je ne sais pas pourquoi
moi quand j'ai expliqué à une personne
très haut placées d'une production ce
que je venais de voir quelques semaines
avant parce que je me suis retrouvé un
endroit où je savais que ça allait être
compliqué et je les fais en interne
parce que j'ai pas la vidéo je peux pas
aller porter plainte on m'a dit alors je
suis pas au courant de cette vidéo par
contre je sais qu'il ya eu des problèmes
avec d'autres personnes d'ailleurs on a
une personne qui ne souhaite pas venir à
cause d'eux ensuite on m'a dit
d'ailleurs les nounous ont été avertis
que ça peut être dangereux donc ils ont
une information qui fait qu' il faut
qu'ils soient un petit peu plus présent
et langil ans pour pas que cette
personne se retrouve seul avec des
jeunes filles qui essaient de ce jeune
homme a envie de se dénoncer
et de dire qu'on parle de lui et le
fasse chez moi j'ai nommé coup là moi je
ne dénonce personnes jeunes et nominé
personne parce que la seule personne les
seules personnes à qui nos minerais les
personnes de cette situation ce sera
face aux institutions qui peuvent faire
quelque chose
assia donc cette jeune fille qui était
prostituée à 14 ans toutes les deux
jennifer assia se bat depuis pour faire
bouger les choses tout a commencé à 14
ans aujourd'hui vous avez 17 ans je
crois tiens quand vous êtes tombée
amoureuse d'un garçon là il avait 17 ans
vous avez 14 ans et au départ vous êtes
il ya le gentil attentionné c'est ça
bout de combien de temps il commence à
vous demander
de faire des choses un peu curieuse j'ai
envie de dire
faites ils sont en fuite ou les deux
du coup la fût que ça coûte de l'argent
ouais donc c'est plutôt ça vole un bus
est présenté comme un petit revenu
spontanée ponctuelles pour payer l'hôtel
payer à manger donkey donc ils lui
disent pour qu'on s'en sorte
de post it oui oui puis en même temps
ils amènent aussi sur le sur le sujet
que si c'est lui qui fait quelque chose
d'illicite il risque la prison et comme
il a déjà commencer à la mettre un peu
sous emprise et l'isoler ci lui va en
prison qui sera là pour elle donc c'est
comme ça que commence ce côté un peu
machiavélique de l'emprise je vous
entendiez bien avec assiettes tout se
passait bien oui alors avec elle ça se
passait bien sauf que moi j'étais en
train d'effectuer une peine d'un an
d'accord une vieille condamnation de
2013 qui découvre en prison que votre
fille
ce procès utile mais aussi tuer alors il
va complètement la coupé de sa famille
de tout en même temps avec l'argent
qu'elle gagne et sur les passes par
exemple il s'est permis de lui offrir
des bagues de fiançailles et de lui
mettre la bague au doigt avec ce qu'elle
avait gagné avec ses fesses quoi il
était capable d'être jaloux de ne pas la
laisser avoir son téléphone de faire le
mec possessif tout en la laissant faire
des clients par jour et où m excusez moi
des termes et des vieux gros dégueulasse
de 60 ans était
pédophile quoi aller 15 ans et un bébé
ça pouvait représenter comme un argent
par jour pour son son proxénète ans ont
été malvenues son procès le bien sans
mal par client
du coup je suis monté à paris la
chercher en fait en me faisant passer
pour un client je les trouvais voilà bon
bref je voulais ramener avec moi à
toulouse et cette première fois on a été
ensemble ce faire elle s'est fait
expertiser a physiquement donc il y
avait elle avait des lésions
des ecchymoses une tuberculose latente
elle avait la gagne 1,8 nécrose nous
aider pour la sortir de là en fait donc
nous arriver c'est quelqu'un qui a un
garçon qui a été la chercher c'est un
garçon qui a fait le client et qui est
ressorti de la chambre avec elle pendant
un mois et demi deux mois on a
franchement elle se reconstruit un petit
peu et reflets sa santé enfin moi je
croyais qu'on avait vu le début du bout
du tunnel est en fin de compte je
n'avais pas anticipé que lui mais il est
revenu à la charge par les réseaux
sociaux il est rongé les ronettes ouais
il irait rendre est alors alors en
contact avec elles tu vous avez fait à
ce moment là mais je me suis pas aperçu
de sa et l'emprise a repris puisqu'elle
m'a volé ma carte bleue et qu'elle a
fugué pour le rejoindre de nouveau
me dit baisser les bras mais mon mari
tout le monde
tout le monde me dit de la chose à faire
mais je peux pas du coup je prends mon
fils de 8 ans et je monte à paris
d'accord vous remontez à paris là où la
retrouver nous venons là sur le coup je
la trouve pas en fait je sais à peu près
où aller mais n'arrive pas à la trouver
ça reste un tout petit peu en contact
avec son frère n'est pas un tout petit
peu ça fait que je sais qu'elle va bien
enfin qu'elle est vivante surtout en fin
de compte parce que je sais rien de plus
et
elle a plus confiance en moi parce que
c'est de l'éloigner de ce mec donc pour
une résidence une autre côté ludique
faut pas que tu retournes et que tu as
d'ailleurs si je passe par quelqu'un en
qui elle a confiance qu'elle connaît
puisqu'elle était enceinte de quelques
mois d'ailleurs d'un prix d'une passe et
je passe par quelqu'un qui l'a fait
revenir tu l'as fait revenir dans le sud
en lui disant je vais m'occuper de toi
fin voilà si le papa de n'ont donc rien
écrire c'est pâques ans et j'ai
l'impression de redescendre par ses
propres moyens en fait parce que si elle
revient pas et qu'elle reste en fixe son
enfant sera placé à la naissance il ya
donc elle revient en fait sans que vous
interveniez d'ici propres roe s'est pas
ma mère soit là que c'est moi qui ai
payé son billet tout mais comme je suis
pas dans l'accord et elle a l'impression
que c'est vraiment elle est en confiance
on est donc là elle elle revient pas
aujourd'hui vous avez vous avez un
enfant donc de quel âge tiens moi dix
mois il s'appelle comment calvin
merci d'être avec nous ce soir merci
d'être avec nous en direct
voilà on voulait avoir votre version des
faits ce soir parce que voilà on veut
cette fois nous avoir les des deux
parties va rappeler de quoi elle vous
vous accuse alix est inhabile
lors d'une soirée 10 voilà vous avez
fait une vidéo avec notamment d'une
jeune fille qui serait apparemment aux
mineurs et que vous l'auriez forcer à
vous faire une fellation elle alors
écrit elle aurait pleuré la vidéo de ce
qu'ils nous ont décrite est extrêmement
choquant est vraiment voilà on les
voyait hier tous les deux apparemment
ils auraient pu cette vidéo c'est la
vidéo avec ce que vous venez d'écrire ça
n'existe pas
je n'ai jamais fait ça de ma vie filmée
ou pas filmer évidemment ça n'existe pas
donc aujourd'hui vous êtes sûr que ça ne
sortira pas parce que si ça existe s'il
existe le moment c'est moi qui ai dit
aux blogueurs parce qu'il ya des
blogueurs qui ont dit on à cette vidéo
il m je leur ai dit sortez cette vidéo
je vous en supplie avant j'aurais dit
sortez la cette vidéo je vous le demande
moi parce qu'elle n'existe pas il n'y a
pas de vidéo il n'y a pas de victime il
n'y a pas de procès il n'y a pas de
plainte j'avais un ancien ami qui
s'appelle sébastien dubois c'est à
l'époque où dans l'altérité on a souvent
on est on peut on peut se lâcher j'étais
fâché que cette personne et ils
voulaient me nuire c'est à dire que lui
il allait raconter ça à nice en disant
moi j'ai vu ça sur ille à gg une vidéo
sur ilan en train de faire c'est en
train de faire ça ok il n'a jamais de
montrer il n'a jamais montré pardon de
vidéos où je suis en train d'agresser
une fiche ne me dit qu'il l'a encore
montré il ya un mois quelqu'un aux états
unis et puis que sans doute après vos
interventions c'est ce qu'on me dit mais
je voulais c'est répondre et peut-être
qu'il aurait été contraint obligé menacé
par vous de supprimer cette vidéo voilà
ce qu'on est alors je vous pose la
question je vous dise qui circulent sur
moi déjà je me lasse persson alors
justement c'est là dessus nabil hier
mais m'a dit que oui mais au contraire
oui mais à un moment donné si vous
commencez goûter nabil qui aujourd'hui
est bannie des réseaux sont devenus
dhabi nous a fait écouter un
nabili vous avez écouté quoi vous a fait
écouter un morceau d'air d'une
conversation enregistrée à mon insu ils
étaient diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux
et sur un plateau télé chose qui est
interdite qui a été montée parce que
dans la conversation il montre sa maison
commence à suffire à envoyer personnes
un avis mais jamais de la vie j'ai jeu
alors il dit qu'il ya un tueur devant
lui battu le fc bale en cela il faut
aller porter plainte faut pas laisser
monter pmp parce que le problème qu'il
ya c'est qu'aujourd'hui une habile c'est
quelqu'un qui avait un rêve d'enfant de
venir ici il a réalisé son rêve et je
suis très content pour lui mais aussi
pour soir mais par contre faut aller
porter plainte parce que quand il ya une
agression sexuelle sur mineur soit
disant mineures parce que entre
guillemets si on pense aux choses qui
sont réelles quand on voit une vidéo
même d'une jeune fille personne que
déterminé ces mineurs ou pas assez dans
un premier temps donc ça c'est une chose
qu'il faut relever de deux ça voudrait
dire que la personne qui a filmé cette
agression sexuelle était là en train de
filmer entendu volée ratée en train
d'agresser une fille sexuellement pas du
tout pas du tout moi c'est possible
comme tu disais cyril il ya peut-être
des vidéos où je rigole avec des filles
alors mais évidemment pas survivre parce
que en fait ce qui se passe et ce qui
est ce qu'on nous a raconté hier c'est
les téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent
c'est donc seb votre aussi un pote qui
aurait montré cette vidéo alix et c'est
lui qui aurait dit regarde la fille est
mineur en plus ya pas de voilà c'est pas
c est lui qui aurait dit voilà un film
dur et madix nous a dit je ne savais pas
qu
à la carrière derrière elle le dit pas
elle n'a pas sa carte d'identité sur son
front c'est ce que voulaient interviewer
le dit pas mais moi je vous explique un
truc aujourd'hui justement sur les
blogueurs qui ont dit qu'ils allaient
sortir cette vidéo moi je les invite à
la sortir la vidéo je les invite à la
sortir comme ça moi au moins je serai
blanchi parce qu'elle n'existe pas
aujourd'hui alix a demandé l'ouverture
d'une enquête le l'enquêté est ouvert ce
que c'est moi qui allait porter plainte
pour diffamation pour dénonciation
calomnieuse pour cyber harcèlement pour
harcèlement et et
pour incitation à la haine la question
que je me pose c'est que moi
personnellement si je suis victime enfin
je suis témoin pardon d'un viol sur
mineur et que la personne qui est en
face de moi à filmer ça je vais à la
police j'attends pas quatre ans pour
aller chez melty sans dire de nom à la
sortie de mon livre
moi c'est ce que tu adores elle a dit
que c'est ce qu'elle sort ayant bâti qui
avait porté plainte c'est ce qu'elle va
lssp faut y aller alors il faut y aller
donc c'est parce que moi j'ai été par
contre moi j'ai vraiment porté plainte
pour diffamation parce que alix pense
que comme tu ne dis pas de nom tu ne
peux pas porter plainte pour diffamation
ce qui est totalement faux et il a juste
pour résumer la vidéo pour vous n'existe
pas dans la vidéo n'existe pas ça
n'existe pas vous n'avez sciemment
envoyé tueur un habit banon donc si vous
êtes tranquille avec ça je suis
tranquille mais je suis plus que
tranquille
[Musique]
combat vous avez reçu énormément de
messages vraiment des massages on vous a
reproché sur les réseaux sociaux
vraiment de faire trop de stratégie vous
êtes fait harceler mais ça que les gens
vous accusent aussi n'ont pas avoir
apprécié votre rivalité avec clémence
castel c'est vrai que franchement il ya
des messages je vais vous lire des
messages ainsi c'est incroyable nous
avons envoyé certaines insultes que vous
aviez reçu c'est très très choquant je
vous dis regardez chuter dehors dehors
sale race
aujourd'hui quand on fait koh lanta non
seulement talara sera de faire koh lanta
est derrière mais en plus tu te dis
quand ça va être diffusé qu'est ce que
je vais me prendre dans la gueule sur
les réseaux faut rappeler je vous
rappelle juste un succulent repas les
gars c'est un jeu c'est un jeu
d'aventuré il faut arrêter si vous avez
reçu des menaces de mort moi j'ai reçu
des menaces de mort desigual sur mes
filles qui remportent avait 4 ans ici
les photomontages dégueulasse enfin j'ai
eu la totale mois il ya eu vraiment de
période koh lanta une première où je
n'existais pas ça me fait rigoler les
gens et à partir du moment où j'ai fait
sortir les premiers favoris on va dire
là j'ai pris cher j'ai vraiment pris
cher mais c'est à base de le générique
défile on vote on va le générique des
films et mon téléphone a sonné dans tous
les sens non je reçois g men linkedin
pour aller y est le lieu de travail de
ma femme qui a fuité aussi donc il y
avait des appels aller lui casser la
tronche mais c'est pareil sur le collège
de mon fils ça s'arrêtait plus en fait à
un point c'était même que mon téléphone
en fait c'est c'est la société c'est à
une paix qui gérait en fait acheté un
tel stade cette saison auprès de deux
aventurières qui sont coumba donc et
christelle c'est sur ça que la
production est intervenue et moi j'ai
échangé avec christelle christelle dans
l'émission j'avais dit qu'elle avait
trouvé le fameux sac de papaye et les
gens c'est délirant les gens se sont mis
à l'agresser en pensant qu'elle avait
dénoncé t où ira alors qu'il s'est
dénoncé tout seul mais elle s'est
trouvée menacée dont elle m'a écrit un
message et les menacer de mort elle est
insultée donc je voudrais dire qu'elle
est exemplaire comme vous dit que c'est
qu'un jeu il faut arrêter quoi elle a
porté plainte avec son avocat sa vie est
devenue un enfer elle est submergée de
messages taraji comme on t'avait la
haine ou tu t'es dit ou tu étais triste
bas j'étais triste sincèrement j'étais
triste parce que j'ai pris beaucoup sur
moi au début je disais rien je désirais
un jeu disent rien mais ils ont réussi à
me faire une si sûr quand même il ya une
scission je vais pas vous mentir il ya
une fissure il ya un moment donné je
voulais pas sortir de dugny en fait je
voulais ils ont réussi alors pourtant
que quelqu'un de très fort tu que tu
deviens jeudi à mi année il ya des jours
j'avais pas envie de sortir du lit où je
resté allongé des jusqu'à midi alors que
moi à 6 heures du matin je vais à la
piscine aussi
venir ensemble il ya ce qu'ils faisaient
penser de la triche de thé our
franchement pas franchement sert il oui
on est affamé ouais
n'importe quelle personne être humain
normal tu es affamés sénile mais je suis
tout à fait opposé à manger à une année
acquis mais tu vas tirs nourris les
chocolats
mais tu sais vous connaissez pas la
vraie fan c'est souvent maintenant on
entend la fin genre j'ai pas pris mon
petit déjeuner j'ai pas pris mon petit
déjeuner j'ai faim j'ai non la vraie fin
c'est quand ton ventre et parle au début
après sur le plus après de mètres de là
près ton ventes atteint souvent mais
rien de bien grands jours qui arrivent
et qui donne à manger se bat bien sûr tu
le prends mais franchement faut arrêter
du jeu de mail algérois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]